[Music]
welcome back to las vegas now as we
continue to stay home
most of us to stay safe during the
pandemic
you might find yourself repeating
certain recipes and maybe even getting
tired of them
well chef chris with smith's food and
drug is here to help
with a brand new recipe that's sure to
spice up your next meal
and hello everybody i'm chef jeff from
smith's okay it's that time of year
where maybe your
favorite football team is playing or
basketball or maybe it's tuesday
taco we're gonna make some queso because
everybody loves queso and it's super
easy
let's get right to it okay so this is a
creamy cheese okay so but it also has
poblano peppers in it now poblano
peppers are these guys here and their
skin is kind of
it's not very appetizing and so what we
do is we char and get it off there let
me just show you how
we do that so if you've got a gas burner
that's perfect because you just put it
right on that flame
and then it starts to char the skin if
you don't have a gas burner
then you put it right in the broiler
just put it like right underneath your
broiler
and then just let it char that way and
you have to flip it over a few times but
either way
once you get it charred then you put it
in a plastic or in a bowl with cover
with plastic wrap
and let it steam for about 10 minutes
and once you do that
then you're left with this beautiful
charred pepper and then you peel it just
super easily and it comes right off
and you chop it and that's our poblano
pepper we're going to put that in here
in a second
okay the next part of this recipe is the
chorizo
let me get this over here so chorizo you
find
in the back of your local marketplace
next to all the mexican cheeses and
things like that
it's just a delicious sausage got a
bunch of spices in it
what i've done is i've browned some i've
got it all browned and ready to go here
crumbled it
i've taken it out and into that same pan
i'm going to go a little bit of oil
after i've taken the sausage out and i'm
going to do those poblano peppers that i
chopped earlier throw those in
and then next goes some onions some
jalapenos because i like it spicy you
could use serrano peppers they're spicy
as well
and then some garlic because we have to
do garlic and just give those a stir
and let them go for three or four
minutes until the onions are translucent
once you've got to that point i have
right here we're going to throw in our
heavy cream
get that in there like so and give it a
stir and once your heavy cream comes to
a
boil or not even a boil more like a
simmer that's when you're going to add
the cheese and so we'll pretend that
that's happening
right here in this pan so we'll add our
cheddar
and then i've got monterey jack and then
i've got
mozzarella and then you just stir that
in and just becomes the super melty
gooey thing and i have one that's
finished right here all
gooey and delicious you see that perfect
and then what you do next is really
simple you just throw some of that cake
or that
sausage back in there not all of it
because i want to save some of it
and then we're going to give it a stir
and our queso is ready to be served
now what you do i would recommend if you
have one of those mini crock pots or
something like that
and hold it warm that way otherwise just
throw it in a
bowl like this it's looking gooey and
awesome
and then what i do after that is just
top it with some extra
chorizo your guests will love it it's
super simple
super flavorful of course you can find
all these ingredients at your local
smiths
thank you so much for watching thank you
for shopping and we will see you guys
all next time bye-bye
to get this recipe and more information
you can visit smithfoodondrug.com
lindsay